cette semaine au ciné c'est un large
éventail de films à voir ou à revoir
jeudi à revoir parce que toujours à la
fiche bohemian rhapsody le film
phénomène qui raconte une partie de la
vie du groupe queen et de son leader
donc toujours à la fiscalité les gens
public j'avais déjà venu voir quatre
cinq six fois on continue à du cous et
venir rapidement
et puis surtout en sortie nationale très
attendue paraît-il
qu'est-ce qu'on a encore fait au bon
dieu avec christian clavier notamment
donc succès attendu le 20 mai 2019 mais
aussi la mule le très bon thriller on va
dire sentimentale de clint eastwood
qu'on n'avait pas vu à l'écran 88 ans
clint eastwood
on n'avait pas vu à l'écran depuis
longtemps donc il reprend son rôle un
peu de personnages boubou qui n'en fait
qu'à sa tête
c'est assez savoureux et puis aux 6 à
pickering
alors ça c'est un film qui raconte
l'histoire de la vie d'oscar wilde et il
passe pour très peu de salles
venez le voir c'est un film de rupert
everett aurait pas eu le cinéma depuis
longtemps avec rupert everett et pour
les plus petits en avant-première
dimanche matin 10h30 et le très attendu
aussi ralph et 2.0 est aussi le très
joli manga japonais mirail ma petite
soeur que vous pouvez revoir semaine sur
nos écrans
[Musique]